joe biden believes he's on the verge of
victory
relief after an undulating night of
anxiety
wrapped in false hope and quiet sighs of
democrat despair
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners
we the people will not be silenced
we the people will not be bullied
we the people will not surrender
my friends i'm confident will emerge
victorious
donald trump is desperately trying to
pump the brakes though
undermine in order to derail quickly
pressing
the nuclear button this is a major fraud
in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
he's since declared two lawsuits in two
states
and claimed victory in all important
pennsylvania
it's predictably gladiatorial talk from
a man whose path is
starting to narrow joe biden
is now the projected winner in wisconsin
a rust belt jewel both men
needed to bag but it's super tight the
president wants a recount
and he'll probably guess it in the last
presidential we did a recount
and what we saw there was there was very
few
if any ineligible ballots that were
identified
in the recount it's there for a reason
so any candidate should
be able to do that at this point in time
i think
you know he's really trying to hold on
to every last string you know hoping
that this recount is going to give him a
victory but
you know nobody's going to really know
until it's over right
after a sluggish start it was here in
arizona
where the map started to look a little
more friendly
to joe biden
a once ruby red state in the sun belt on
the cusp of turning blue
a new political future painted by a
young latino population
the last night didn't deliver some
reversal of the national political
narrative
it was a fittingly messy scramble for a
horribly divided country
team trump now launching legal action in
closely fought michigan
it's not just america's future at stake
now but it's democratic reputation
here's another indisputable take-home
donald trump
increased his vote share getting at
least three million more people to vote
for him
than in 2016. a vast number of americans
looked at what he had to offer over the
past
four years and signed up for four more
surely no one can now see his political
rise
as an historic collaboration
win or lose mr trump will emerge more
powerful than ever
inside the republican party defying
expectations for himself
and helping others to surprise victories
[Applause]
joe biden's prospects are far more
complex
even if he were to make it to the white
house he likely won't get the senate
without that it could be four years of
ugly gridlock
cordelia lynch sky news washington